well we find that the both its genetic
in both of males rgr almost always
higher on the general trait particularly
on those scales subscales that that deal
with impulsivity like we call them
disinhibition for instance one scale and
another thrill and adventure seeking
these are things men are particularly
high on these are things also that peak
and adolescence and decline with age so
that's an interesting thing because
sensation-seeking also Peaks Nautilus
higher and men than women peaks in
adolescents like late late adolescence
and declines with age
well in the past sensation-seeking was
found in just the struggle for survival
hunting I've imagined the successful
hunters were men who enjoyed it even at
the risk of hunting large mammals or
mammoths and things like that war has
always been fighting among menace it
still is related to sensation-seeking
but in modern Western society or there's
no war most people find their sensation
in other kinds of activities for
instance thrilling adventure seeking
well ordinary sports don't provide much
of that exceptional sports like
skydiving and hang gliding and
whitewater rafting and things like that
provide the sensation thrilling
adventure seeking for minority people
who engage in them your moon average man
for instance fine says sensation-seeking
the way drives us car you know and we
find the high sensation seekers are more
risky drivers they drive at higher
speeds young males have more accidents
the they tailgate they they use their
cars as a vehicle for thrill and
adventure seeking an aggression yeah do
you think but when I add the doctor
sensation-seeking isn't all thrill and
adventure seeking sensation seeking has
outlets through through those no other
aspects through through sex for instance
which is a part of them again the reason
for its survival it was involved in
seeking a mates and some in the some men
and women need a lot of variety in their
sexual outletzon behavior and others
don't need that much variety and
therefore are more monogamous and so
that's in one area drugs drinking drugs
these are all outlets for sensation
seekers okay involving different kinds
of risk but involving risk nevertheless
well there is a four types of
risk-taking which form the core of you
might say of smoking drinking drugs and
sex okay now you can see three of those
are substance abuses and they act
through the central nervous system they
act on centers in the central nervous
system that give intrinsic pleasure okay
particularly stimulant drugs like
cocaine you know they provide pleasure
they provide the kick that activities
provide like sex provide for the for the
sensation seeker and they're all
correlated because they're all aspects
of intensity seeking sensation ok and
then novelty too there's a difference
minutes and drug users between those are
high sensation seekers and those are low
I found this out when I was treating
drug abusers the low sensation to weld
the average and low sensation seeing
drug abuser tries one drug which he
enjoys particularly and sticks to it the
loaves try many different drugs so
normally they get into odd drugs like
LSD that affect their minds as well as
their you know their provide unusual
sensations as well as arousal the lows
stay away from those drugs I remember
once in Iran and the discussion with in
this drug abusing community and they
were relating their drug experiences and
one of them was a high sensation seeking
a LSD user and he was talking about that
he and another one was shaking his head
and they asked him a jungle what what
why are you you know what do you think
of this says man that's crazy this is a
heroin egusi understand that stain why
would anyone fool that that's dangerous
the fuck with your mind you know he just
can understand that he just used heroin
which you know which eventually
initially provides some highs but
eventually is used because it's quits
because of the lows it's just you know
they because you need it to stay feeling
normal okay
you find for instance that high
sensation seekers among the not many men
who love war in combat but there are a
few there are some who are really find
that exciting and will revolve tier
simply because they're bored with
military life outside of combat and
they're in various substances which are
interesting and that they stimulate the
same centers that that are stimulated by
intense and novel stimuli external
stimulation drugs do that more directly
particularly drugs like cocaine